so the debate is about the fact that as
human beings we seem to form
particularly strong attachments to those
who are close to us to where we belong
to our family to our community to we
might say our tribe and the questions
that we're going to be thinking through
today is is that a good thing we're
going to be asking whether there's a
danger in tribalism and of course that
seems to be a very resonant and pressing
question for us now in the context of
brexit in the context of Trump in the
context of us of a sort of discursive
space now where arguably it's legitimate
to talk about being a nationalist in a
way that it wasn't necessarily twenty
years ago so that is our question those
are our issues to help us think about
them we are very lucky to have David
Miller a professor of political theory
at Oxford homi Bhabha professor of the
humanities at Harvard and finally and
wonderfully we have Yasmine Abdul Majeed
a writer and activist and a mechanical
engineer can we justify our tribal
allegiances or are they a source of
conflict and division and I shall begin
by asking David to start thanks Hanna
that's great so well all the evidence we
have is that people are quite deeply
tribal by nature they genetically
programmed to find a group to identify
with yeah at the same time which group
that is is quite contingently can be
pushed in one way or another so tribes
may have started out as biological kin
groups but it's not difficult for us to
transcend our ethnic origins and find
new identities so why do we have this
innate need to belong to a tribe what
does it do for us I think two things
mainly first it allows us to put our
individual life histories into a much
bigger picture maybe there are some
people who can get by with just an
individual personal narrow
but for most of us I think taking an age
in which religion has lost its power for
most people we need a bigger master
narrative to make sense of our own lives
a story that begins in the past and
projects into the future and I think
it's nothing sadder than being the very
last member of your tribe like the last
person to speak a dying language the
other thing it does for us is it gives
us a kind of recognition we all crave to
be respected but it matters who's
offering the respect and the people who
count are the people whose tribe we're
part of so as you can see I'm an
academic and what matters to me is the
respect I get from other academics and
bus drivers probably think what I do is
a complete waste of time maybe right it
doesn't bother me that doesn't bother me
so now why isn't it enough just to be
respected as a human being and I think
that's too emptier description what
about for your individual achievements
well that's fine if you're Usain Bolt or
edge here and but I think for most of us
there's nothing very special that we've
achieved so what matters is that we're
seen as being a good enough member of
the tribe that we belong to so tribes do
good things for their own members but
don't they create problems for outsiders
what about inter tribal conflicts well I
think essentially these arise when one
tribe poses a threat to the well-being
or the very existence of another so
classically tribe a invades the hunting
grounds of tribe B so the important
thing is to give tribes a secure space
to operate in and the big problem occurs
when a whole society divides along
tribal lines whether these are ethnic or
religious or political because then
physical separation becomes impossible
that's what we want to avoid at all
costs and the way to do it is to have an
inclusive identity so that people who
have unavoidably to live together can
all see themselves as belonging to
one big tribe and that's why I'm happy
to call myself a liberal nationalist
because I see nation-building as the
constructive way to the to respond to
the human need to belong that I'm saying
is inescapable I'm not even so sure that
we should describe the conflicts we have
today as tribal first of all I think the
word tribal is a particular
anthropological understanding of an
ecology of people living together in
different times than the ones we do and
I just got to say that you know is this
translation is this metaphor the right
one now do we are we all really proud of
our families that we already proud of
the nations we belong to a simplistic we
love our parents we hate our parents our
parents [ __ ] us up what did Philip Locke
advanced right a parent sometimes [ __ ]
ourselves then we recover our nations we
love we we fight of the the patriotism
of our nation because we think it's
misguided so I think that there are a
whole complex set of feelings even in
the most intimate institutions of our
lives and that doesn't fit well with
this narrow notion of you know you love
where you came from many of us come from
many different places in our lives and
each time we embed or see the certain
kind of home and I think that we've got
to think about that in the world in
which we live now I also think that this
idea of universal humanity doesn't
really work
after all it's a very important issue
that we have in the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights but very
often we think of universal humanity
after we have persecuted people after we
persecute people then we could set up
these you know even in the Enlightenment
you know after the 30-year war you began
to get the issue of actually
constituting nations and this is my
point
nations are our tribes
and the good and the evil come together
because we our nations are our tribes
how we constitute within a nation a set
of convergent beliefs practices a sense
of a sense of common purpose that's very
important but at the moment we are
seeing tribal nationalism and tribal
nationalism it is a term I get from
Hannah Arendt writing in a period very
near our like our own in the interwar
period where you had mass migrations and
nation-states were either forming or
being deconstructed and what she says
about tribal nationalism I think is
something we have to urgently hear today
she says tribal nationalists or tribal
national moments are constituted often
by large masculinist fingers with 64 in
chests who believe and this is the
description that mr modi gives of
himself I have a 64 in chest I will take
all the beatings for my people I have a
broad chest mr. Trump has his own before
by which he thought of you know holds up
no policy no argument but he does have
this rather impressive before and he
tries to live by so the whole issue
really here is how do we how do we
defeat this nationalist issue and I just
want to say that the best way to do this
is to make ourselves aware of what the
symptoms of it are whatever the economic
discontents whatever the failures of
globalization whatever the failures of
the EU why is it that in every country
every time the issue always comes up as
my immigration racism ethnic policy
whatever the economic issues are it is
unquestionable that african-americans in
America do worse than white that then
then the oppressed and in a way
suffering white populations there's no
question about that make the good-doers
but somehow as soon as we have within
the nation-state form
some forms of nationalism it's always
race gender sexuality femininity that
begins to become the enemy of the people
and I think we've got to be very clear
about that as a symptom it's not the
cause it's the symptom it's not the
cause of reason it's not the cause of
the wall being built between Mexico in
the United States I want to end actually
with a voice much finer than mine a poem
about I believe a short term about
populist nationalism or tribal
nationalism by WH Auden it's called
diaspora how he survived them they could
never understand how the victim somehow
survives the oppressor that's what
drives the tyrant man how he survived
them they could never understand had
they not beggared him themselves to
prove they could not live without their
dogmas or their land no worlds they
drove him from wherever big enough how
could it be the earth the unconfined
meant when it bade them to set no limits
to their love on heat with fear he drew
their terrorists to him and was a
godsend to the lowest of mankind till
there was no place left where they could
still pursue him except that exile which
they called his race but envying him
even that they plunge right through him
into a land of mirrors without time for
space and all they had to strike now was
the human face
[Applause]